so for this week's classic interview I
want to go back to an interview that's
now almost 5 years old it's from 2014
with Bill Blunden who's a cyber security
and surveillance expert because of the
recent change to Julian Assange is
status not having Asylum anymore from
the Ecuadorian Embassy in London with
discussions of WikiLeaks cyber hacking
Russia the Trump campaign 2016
bill Blunden when I interviewed him back
in 2014 had extraordinary insights into
a lot of these issues and sort of more
general or overarching ways that I think
are very very interesting to go back to
you so let's do that now
my interview with Bill Blunden from May
of 2014
take a look bill Blunden joins me today
he's an independent computer security
researcher also author of the book
behold a pale farce cyber war threat
inflation and the malware industrial
complex bill it's great to talk to you
and thanks for being here this is just
generally an area where legitimate fears
and hyperbole seem to mix and sometimes
it's hard to tell what's what so let's
start with maybe the broadest question
when it comes to cyber warfare and
malware what really are the most
pressing risks that the average everyday
American should be aware of well I
definitely think that there is an awful
lot of cyber crime I mean if you look at
the target breach recently I believe it
cost targets something like 200 million
dollars to recover from that and there's
also espionage obviously some of it
we're involved in and there's sabotage
too if you look at Stuxnet you know we
sabotage their uh their Iranian
enrichment facility so there's I would
say there's lots of cyber crime there's
espionage there's sabotage and while
they they aren't existential problems I
think there's serious problems and they
would they need to be addressed and I
think on a day-to-day basis those are
the real threats the average person is
going to face so let's talk about some
of the doomsday scenarios that maybe
people have heard about in fact some
that some guests on our program have
talked about in more detail so these
would be a total takedown of the elect
the electrical grid for the country or
parts of the country attacking the
banking system in a way
that would make everyday transactions
impossible financial markets and
significantly affecting the everyday of
financial transactions that were
involved in how real are those threats
in your opinion I think from the
standpoint of statistical analysis there
is no data on any of this with you know
there are plenty of metaphors they use
they use terms like cyber 9-1-1 cyber
katrina cyber war they use terms like a
cyber armageddon or cyber getting
shortened and like I said there's no
data on this so it's hard to really make
a solid prediction at least from a
quantitative standpoint but the people
who are promoting these ideas they sent
up they tend to focus on how bad it'll
be when it happens and I think this is
their tell that this is not intended
this message isn't intended to appeal to
reason it's there to appeal to emotion
it's there to incite an emotional
response it's there to elicit anxiety
and to kind of foment a crisis mentality
this is code was called threat inflation
this is the it's a it's a propaganda
technique that's being used and we saw
it before in the Iraq war when President
Bush and other White House officials
talked about The Smoking Gun that came
in the form of mushroom cloud and when
you get someone who's in an anxious
position who's you know kind of in a
crisis mentality they'll pay any amount
of money to be safe but if you think
about a rational person even though
there are several types of insurance you
could buy there's a whole there's
countless types of insurance but you
don't go out and buy every type of
insurance you carefully compute what
your risk is to each threat and then you
make a cost-benefit analysis and you
decide carefully how you're gonna
protect yourself and when you're in this
crisis mentality when you're anxious and
you you've been kind of subjected to
threat inflation you're in a position
where you can waste a lot of resources
and yield up your civil liberties and
try to protect yourself at a very high
cost when and in doing so neglect these
genuine threats that we face on a
day-to-day basis I think that the actual
threat of cyber Armageddon is
pretty low and a lot of officials agree
with this the people who run the grid
organizations the North American
Electric Reliability corporation the the
the chief executive that organization
says we're not worried about the cyber
threat we're far more worried about the
physical threats and and that would make
sense because they're actually al are a
lot of instances where they're in
physical instances that brought down
what brought down power and the same
thing with the banking industry I think
that people don't give the banking
industry enough credit large financial
institutions like the Federal Reserve
they have all sorts of elaborate
disaster recovery measures in place and
they go to lengths to great lengths they
have professionals who are dedicated to
keeping these networks safe and to think
that you know that you're gonna you know
disable our financial institutions they
keep backups you know and they keep them
in vaults under ground I think to to
stop an institution like the Federal
Reserve to really grind it to a halt
over the over a long term you'd probably
need a nuclear for a strike
so you mentioned something interesting
there which was the amount that you're
willing to give up in terms of privacy
or civil liberties seems to be directly
correlated to how afraid or anxious you
are about a particular scenario and
we've talked about this quite a bit
recently in light of the revelations
from Edward Snowden which if you had
paid attention to the passing of the
Patriot Act and if you saw the level of
fear and thus what Americans were
willing to accept in the immediate
aftermath of 9/11 you wouldn't really
have been that surprised by the
revelations of Edward Snowden which
kinds of kind of gets us to another area
I wanted to ask you about we often hear
the response to news that there is
surveillance being done of Americans of
listen I'm confident I'm not doing
anything wrong and therefore I just
don't really care go ahead and spy on me
I don't really care it makes no
difference to me in general my responses
to that is we'll listen
we have a certain level of over
criminalization in this country and even
if you truly believe you're not really
doing anything wrong having this
information in the hands of different
government agencies may at some point in
the future who even knows what laws you
may be breaking or may
have retro actively broken at some point
and that makes me very cautious but I'm
wondering are there better arguments
against those who say hey I'm doing
nothing wrong I don't care I think that
we need to understand very clearly that
these civil liberties are safeguards
against oppression against despots and
they the people who created who founded
them believed enough to die for them and
anyone who's who's grown up my wife grew
up in Beijing during the Cultural
Revolution she knows what it's like to
live in a police state anyone who lived
in Russia during the reign of Stalin
understands why you need these why you
need these liberties why they're
important because you don't know how
much you miss them until they're taken
away and I think to an extent we're
starting to see signs of the same
illness here in United States for
example the 2012 National Defense
Authorization Act has detainment
provisions which are very unsettling for
journalists and activists who could be
deemed cooperating with terrorists
somehow and be detained without any sort
of due process I think that you know
this hole right now we we exist in a
surveillance state it's I have no doubt
in my own mind that we have you know the
corporate players and the government's
the government spies had put in place a
mechanism where they can monitor almost
everything at real-time and and to to
assume that our secret policies you know
which are judged by by courts that are
secret and and issue mandates their
secret to believe that this secret
mechanism will safeguard us from devolve
into a police state I think is really
the height of recklessness I think it's
really it's a huge threat to our to our
democratic republic see it's interesting
because I agree with a lot of what
you're saying bill and the issue I have
and I asked this not in a rhetorical
sense but this is really an internal
discussion that we have all the time on
the program which is on the one hand I
generally tend to agree with the ideas
yours
pausing when it comes to surveillance
although maybe in a little bit less of a
I don't know apocalyptic sense but at
the same time there's a crossover
between the beliefs you've just espoused
with regard to surveillance and the
extreme pro-gun Second Amendment
gun-toting enthusiasts that are
supporting all sorts of laws that I
think are quite destructive in different
states around the country do you see the
two sides as one battle so to speak or
do you see how the two may be different
I think that if you wanted to really
draw a distinction between the civil
libertarians and the libertarians it has
to do with the ultimately the role of
government obviously libertarians they
believe they can exist without
government and my response to that is if
you want to see what it's like to live
in a society without any government go
hang out in the tribal regions of
Pakistan for a little while the civil
libertarians they believe that
governments actually it should be there
as a safeguard against people things
like people dumping toxic waste for
example or the banks who are running
rampant right now ostensibly the
government center to safeguard us
obviously it's not doing a very good job
with that
mm-hmm but I think in terms of civil
libertarians and libertarians you have a
basically right left kind of it has to
do the difference between the two has to
do with role of government but I think
there is some common ground in terms of
the idea of are we going to trade
Liberty for security and there was an
op-ed piece that was written by Tom
Friedman in the New York Times several
months back it was called blowing the
whistle and he basically said his
argument was that we should give up a
little bit of our Liberty our Liberty
just give up a little dissolute we can
prevent an attack which will end up
taking away all of our freedoms so this
attack will be so great this terrorist
attack would be so apocalyptic that it
will it will end all of our other
freedoms and we'll end up you know in a
really bad situation so he said I'd be
willing to give up a little
a little liberty out front to to
safeguard ourselves against such an
attack and I think there was enough
negative response that Bill Keller
actually wrote a second op-ed shortly
afterwards reinforcing and trying to
bolster Tom Friedman's position but
ultimately they're both saying that we
should undermine the Constitution to
save it and it reminds me of Iraq where
we said we have to destroy Iraq in order
to save it and I think that even our
founding fathers disagreed with this
Benjamin Franklin for example said those
who would yield essential Liberty on
behalf of a little temporary security
deserve neither liberty or security hmm
and I I agree I think in this case you
know it's not terrorism that destroys
freedom it's our response to terrorism
that destroys freedom the British
government back during World War two
when they were being bombed by the
Germans they would hang these signs out
that said remain calm carry on right and
I think that's what we need to do I
think if you look at how Japan handled
the nerve gas attacks by the Amish and
Riccio did they rely on indefinite
detention did they torture people did
they use mass interception did they
suspend civil liberties they didn't do
any of that no they had their police
conduct investigations they indicted
people and they tried them in a civilian
court very simple very straightforward
they remain calm and they carried on and
I think that's what we need to do as a
country very interesting the distinction
between civil libertarians and
libertarians definitely something we're
going to explore further the book is
behold a pale farce bill blundin thanks
so much for joining us today thank you
David